the mtv video music awards took over new
jersey's prudential center last night
and we we need to check in on all the
swifties out there as it was pretty much
a taylor swift takeover
yeah that's right taylor had everyone
shook when she dropped a bombshell
announcement that she's releasing a
brand new album this fall and i think
it's safe to say taylor's award show bob
is a whole mood okay because she's
really everyone's number one fan from
the crowd as she was captured rocking
out to black pink and nicki minaj while
making sure everyone stood up to cheer
for the rapper as she was honored with
the vanguard award take a look
[Applause]
[Applause]
excuse me
[Applause]
[Music]
like she's really the audience member
everyone
should have at their concert right like
she's really the audience member you
want in there she's singing along to all
the music she's up on her feet trying to
get everybody else hype
that's what we want that's a good energy
yeah yeah no she gives good award show
energy like i feel like she just knows
to be on she knows people are looking at
her she's not gonna be just sitting
there looking boring she's gonna
you know spice it up she's part of
everyone's fan club she's like the
ultimate hype girl like yes yes yes and
of course
and what she was wearing
yeah her outfit was top of the list for
you top of the list for you
yeah it was top of the list for me it
was sexy it was still glamorous
it showed enough but not too much i just
it was it was giving for me girl go live
your little life okay
that's the balance you need the balance
of everything i know people are really
excited for that announcement too that
new music announcement wow holy people
just going on screen
um alex j says i can't wait for taylor
swift's new album in october taylor
swift dancing is the best at awards
shows
um
yeah vista says love taylor swift
you know a lot of crowns a lot of fire
from kevin that's it
very excited